[Music]
i wanted to ask you a question what's up
so this is really serious should we be
here right now
no okay no i mean this topic is serious
okay but the way i started it okay
anyway
so somebody died
here is kind of it's really tragic
actually so
they are reporting now that in brazil
there are a lot of indigenous
communities that are being
severely affected uh with kovid to the
point where
a whole bunch of like the wise ones like
the elders
of these indigenous communities um have
passed and so
with them they're taking like knowledge
decades and generations and generations
of knowledge of their culture to the
point where they're saying like right
now
they're like facing extinction it's like
smallpox number two it's crazy
is it like they just weren't notified of
it
so the thing is in brazil um like i
don't know if the indigenous people live
with amongst the regular people do they
have their they live in their own
communities but the thing is
because in brazil right now like kobe's
so
intense and so these indigenous
communities they need to get resources
and
the government isn't really taking care
of them to the point where now they're
being forced
to go out into the the community like
the
cities and stuff and actually get
resources to to survive
there's not enough bananas no offense
how indigenous are they if they can't
get [ __ ] from the land yeah okay because
when i think of indigenous i'm thinking
the amazonian tribes that nobody can
contact
contact with brazil that was basically
like yeah there's covey but we don't
really care who's gonna ride it out
that's mexico
was it yeah but for a while yeah i i'm
well the president was saying [ __ ] like
that yeah
i'm thinking of more like uh like if
they're so
closed off like you're saying they gotta
go into the village to get
supplies like get bottles of water or
something well i think they're like
indigenous but not like um
maybe the tribes separate from the world
or anything because i know they have the
tribes that
have contact and then they keep
preserving their culture yes
and then people come and the way that
they make money is through tourism
right so they're not like fully like um
what's the word yeah cut off yeah yeah i
[ __ ] hate you
because he says some really wise some
deep [ __ ] yeah this is going on yeah and
i'm so invested
and then i zoom out to see the full
picture let's see these [ __ ] things
like the economy
thrives off of tourism guys okay if you
could see that he's also barefoot right
now
it would help as well my feet need to
breathe man i got eczema right now
it's just hard like you're saying some
very profound
things yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
you know what the [ __ ] be happening in
the [ __ ] world today
will you run for governor california
[ __ ] yeah dude you know i would i'm
voting for you five times i want to
prove to the world
that i could kill it in this
[ __ ] race by being my true self
and showing that i'm superior
i want to be your campaign manager okay
okay thanks oh yeah so
you guys are asking like well if they're
so indigenous and secluded then why are
they getting coveted well the thing is
government health workers that we're
going into these communities
like some of these leaders are actually
blaming the government workers who went
to go visit they've been coughing on a
mission
they're the culprits who gave them that
makes sense
yeah yeah so that's happening right now
and it's um
it's really sad because it is sad for
one
group of people in particular they have
lost 10
other wise wise ones the elders yeah
they're the elders exactly and so
they're saying that they
they are like living libraries that it's
been very painful
so they don't have a written language
and then they have these like
old old guys that remember everything
and he didn't didn't write anything
down right
they should've you should have wrote it
down man
i'm sure they wrote something i sure
hope so
you guys are so [ __ ] american i hate
it here it's just the way he looks
it's just the way he looks that's the
situation yeah it has nothing to do with
what's coming out of his mouth what do
you think i'm dealing with i'm just
[ __ ] campaign manager it's a
nightmare i think he's the [ __ ]
juxtaposition of the [ __ ] outside of
the inside
i'm just saying okay it kind of sucks if
only one person in your team remembers
everything
not just that i mean it's like they are
like
you know the chiefs the elders the
the traditional healers of these
communities i think that in addition to
like
if there's if there's like they're kind
of like a president right like
a present actually does [ __ ] where it's
like if there's some issues happening
amongst the community then they
that they bring that problem to the
elders
the whole community of wise ones can
like
work it out but i don't know nothing
about indigenous peoples right
so i'm speaking that from a place of
ignorance i'm just kind of like
well if he's the shaman the historian
all this stuff and he's gone who's gonna
help the other people when he's sick
and why why are these few people holding
so many titles they should have spread
the positions around
that's what i'm saying the historian is
also the shaman
and also no one said that baptizer and
also
the i don't know oh yeah i mean there's
just a lot of like the elder
people so multiple people many hats yeah
i wanna i wanna talk about shamans
because i just watched this whole video
about
um like natural healers and sidekicks in
the community
a lot of the times they don't [ __ ]
wanna be the shaman why
because they still gotta do whatever
duties they have to do right like the
goat
hurting or the [ __ ] like whatever
normal things people have to do
like survive you have five children
right
you still got to do that and now you're
the village
now you're a dealer you're going to go
find an eye on newt and you're like god
damn i'm so tired from hurting you
but i i heard a lot of the times people
don't [ __ ] want to be the shaman
because they're like
oh damn naw i got these gifts and [ __ ]
and i got a heal but are they nominated
like how do people know about these
gifts
they know that uh they have gifts at an
early age
because they go through certain um
well in in the western world i would say
hallucinations or like we would write it
off as
like mental issues like you're you might
having psychosis or whatever right like
they have these special powers
and um these natural abilities are
interpreted
in these other communities as like
something special
and then they get guided with a mentor
and this happens a lot like whether it's
tibet
or the indigenous people of america or
whatever like
it typically happens where early on in
childhood
when someone has these episodes someone
in the community who's either
experienced that themselves or like an
older shaman
they mentor that craft and then they
figure out a way to
kind of live with this uh uh special
power that they
flick the shining it's like you have a
shine to you kind of thing is what you
think
and then a lot of times they don't want
it because they're like oh man i gotta
do this and i gotta still hurt goats
like what about just being a shaman can
i just do that and get paid for that
yeah so i'm gonna do other [ __ ]
i gotta go catch a [ __ ] live bat for
a potion for someone who [ __ ] saved
your lives i'm not living very well guys
yeah for me when i read the story like i
was really thinking about the tragedy of
like losing an entire culture because
it's like
that's like that's like irreplaceable
like how do you
how do you move on from i know man i
don't know how i can live with
people going what anime what dirty
underwear what
see and then like so much so many people
care like they like about japan right
and what if a volcano just goes away and
all of a sudden like i'm a part of this
like
forgotten place where guys would marry
robots
all the weebs here that's the culture
the weebles some of it and the closest
thing you could do is maybe
ask the rival tribe for
what do you guys remember about us but
that's like asking like salvadorians
about mexican history first of all your
leader was a [ __ ] you should know that
[ __ ] or who else because you you have to
go to another elder
but then those elders remember you a
completely different way yeah i think
that would like what jeff's saying it's
so sad because you see a whole culture
disappear and that's why if you're a
culture out there just start writing
this [ __ ] down that's what i would do
whatever whatever is going on in your
culture just start transcribing it
but like the bloodline too like what if
it's just you're the last
person of your bloodline and if they
don't know how to write
can we just [ __ ] record them yeah in
their stories taking videos
and upload it on youtube so then
at least if they need to
there's a [ __ ] proof there of what
happened or at least if like
if like the the first person in a tribe
starts coughing immediately go tell me
some stories please
yo let's hear it yeah oh that's food no
but if he tells the stories you're gonna
get sick but at least you could write it
down
start emailing that [ __ ] yeah i don't
know the minute people start coughing
you gotta write [ __ ] down [ __ ] stacey
you gotta write the [ __ ] down guys
that's why i asked canada do these
tribes have a okay
legitimate question do they know writing
legitimate question like i wanna guess
yes i want to guess yes
because because just because you're
indigenous doesn't mean you don't know
how to read it right like
they they still send some other kids
they have their own language
they still send their kids to school or
whatever right but like what's happening
is that
some of these groups i'm assuming is
just all oral history so then when the
shamans die or the old people dies
it just all ends with that or just don't
be like me i recorded my dad telling his
life story twice
and you deleted it one of them got
corrupted the other one got you're the
worst
dude really yeah i really am i gotta do
it third time now this was probably so
sick of his own story i'm sorry
no oh he gets better at telling it
probably dude
i told you this one already man goddamn
dude i heard my grandpa talk about
vietnam
so many times but i kept falling asleep
you're dead no my grandpa
so i don't know i don't really know what
he did in vietnam that much i know some
of it but not that much
you know there's like a [ __ ] ton of uh
tribes still that are
uh what do you call it uncontacted in
the amazon
yeah i mean that's there's that violent
one the super violent one
oh cause they they just shoot [ __ ]
trains i mean uh helicopters
dude the one where that christian guy
tried to go into that village and he's
like yo
i want to bring jesus to you and they
[ __ ] him up that's in uh that's in
india
yeah yeah yeah that one island right
yeah it's an island the sentinelese
so that's an elise yeah yeah so this is
a kayak oh do you know why
oh man they look good i don't know why
that tribe got so uh
violent because they got sick in the
past when they made contact no because
it's a missionary that came
and he was molesting all the members and
cutting off
like dismembering them examining their
genitals and [ __ ]
yeah and so after that they're like no
outsiders they're crazy
what a [ __ ] yeah i hope they killed
the [ __ ] but this was like
300 years ago or some outrageous amount
of time like it was like mad years ago
right they hold
on to grudges they wrote down the grudge
that's what you do
that's what that's how you pass it down
you